my name is PewDiePie and I'm here to
answer one and one simple question can
wish make me satisfied I am not
satisfied I want to be satisfied a
shiatsu massage massage
that might make me satisfied that guy
looks pretty damn satisfied all right it
will make you happy 21 buckaroony by day
I buy it ooh black back black back
massage chair car SUV hot seat oh oh is
this for cars
no can I yeah you can still plug it in
okay absolutely what do people say all I
know I love it my boyfriend going to
love it too all right it uh Tilly works
well wish it heated up what she did up
as well okay Sweden is not sure about it
v-shaped face before
okay
you get a v-shaped face that could be
satisfying I'm satisfied if I gotta be
[ __ ] faced I think that every day what
if I had a v-shaped face everything
would be so much better 60 days of real
shooting
don't go real shooting it's funny it
actually looks kind of luxurious it
looks like an Apple product Oh we get
customer photos wow they look so cool
I can't wait to get my v-shaped face
y'all gonna be so jealous all the haters
are slamming their disk I massager
with heat compression Bluetooth what it
cures Gamers it cure I'm gamer I need it
I feel like unironically this might be
really comfy I have no idea we're gonna
find out maybe some satisfying the best
of the best according to Syria okay imma
buy it 24 baccaronis it's a Gamba I'm
willing to take oh yes this I need
stainless steel extending back scratcher
yes that will make me Beyond only one
pound thousand reviews this is perfect
oh Franz hates it oh my God French
people hate this product I get this
problem every time I work out I don't
know if there's something with your
brain where it's like oh you can't reach
this one part in your back now it itches
now it's the worst I need I actually
need this it's pretty sturdy I'm sold
anything sturdy and I want it hell yeah
two PCS summer mug with traditional
Chinese medicine self-heating support
knee pads knee knee pads knee pads
warmer hell yeah oh I'm gonna be so
comfortable I'm Gonna Be So Satisfied
two buckaroonis buy it I don't know what
is this but I know I want it electric
cervical neck okay hell yeah buy it I
realize I gotta have something for my
feet as well I'm gonna get one of these
I've all I've actually own ironically
really want to try these all right 14
bucks one review says okay yeah I don't
see how it could go wrong I really don't
buy it but the most important thing that
I will buy today to make me the most
satisfied is the menstrual heating pad
electric heating vibration massage I
feel like guys could use this as well
additional massage pleasure see I want
it and it's pink I want it I buy it
there's only 28 left I better hurry up
as a final to tip it all up I'm gonna
get one of these yeah magic tricks
appear in Kane before after that's cool
and I won it buy it maybe that will make
me the most satisfying alright let's
wait for these items to arrive and by
the time that this
I am prepared to get satisfied luckily
the police hasn't uh didn't come this
time around which I appreciate thank you
I don't remember ordering this Chinese
man has gifted us I must have ordered
this and completely forgot
oh we're following a trend here I see
with cute outfit why am I wearing
headphones anyway oh very cowboy Oh
bag
cute it's not what I wanted ah yes
intelligent explanation of tingling oh
no oh no am I gonna die
intelligent cervical massager it doesn't
seem like it's been used already at all
I really really like that
what is this then
okay so it comes with this and a remote
and a battery how do I charge it oh
I don't know why I bought this I don't
I'm supposed to be satisfied
all right come on [ __ ]
am I supposed to feel something oh
we play horror games I ain't scared
putting Chinese product on your neck
intense fear okay I'm gonna press the
massage button
so far I am not satisfied and I oh
here's how you charge it I didn't see
we'll let that charge up while I unbox
more why do I I think I have a shopping
problem because I'm buying stuff I had
don't even remember buying what the hell
is this oh this might be from a last
video oh oh it is very satisfying oh
it's like a weird fidget spinner
oh
[Music]
it's magnetic oh oh oh that's weird oh
satisfaction level
two
it's pretty nice
oh
oh that's weird
I don't know how to describe it magnet I
don't I feel the stress relieving my
body yes
the V phase
whitening Rejuvenation wait it's
whitening I don't want to be whitened I
want to be vegan I didn't want the most
handsome last year and I think I need to
step it up you know
oh God I need to charge this as well
damn it I was hoping they were
electrical plug I know what these days
God I'm I'm really starting with the
lame stuff huh
yeah yes
I think out of all why would they put
that on there why I'm not satisfied at
all God damn it that's never coming up
it's like when they put it on those
[ __ ] game cartridges dude that's way
longer than I anticipated what was the
review ow
what was the reviewers talk oh
oh that's good okay and not a tank love
me
hey something something behind your ear
a rose
or madame
[Music]
subscribe
I think I had an initially in another
idea for this video and then we made a
change of me being satisfied and now
it's just confusing
uranium
bro
what in the name of cancer did I buy
here I'm gonna put that away
I bought so much more stuff than I
thought about yo check this out Apex
yeah
[Music]
Apex butterfly knife
oh
that's not that bad actually I mean it's
really bad for flipping but it doesn't
look that bad let's put this away before
cops I didn't know I have in my hand
nothing but a thread
damn it
now
it's a Lethal Weapon
I am not satisfying give me the massage
sunglasses
foreign
okay let's open the big ones I'm tired
of this
cool I like American plug amazing you
thought the PewDiePie chair couldn't get
any better oh yeah
okay let's try on
oh
oh intensity oh
oh it goes on my butt hey I like this
one oh
uh
oh sorry video that's a solid seven I
love it my satisfaction meter is going
up so I've had it going up [ __ ] what
else we got I want a thousand percent
satisfaction
if only knives weren't illegal yes oh
holy
[ __ ] you know when you walk past some
stores that are super old and you're
just like bam they really kept those
things in the window for like how many
years look at this box dude it's so
bleached by the sun easy brain massager
what the [ __ ] did I buy a brain massager
oh God yes get this baby open enhance
memory it enhance his memory I will
learn Japanese in five seconds once I
get my brain massage I'm never if it's
Christmas
brain massage
I don't recall but what
my brain will reach New Heights
what in the actual what how is this a
thing increased memory increased memory
is it going to lobotomize me I sure hope
it's so okay I'm playing it into my
brain now I'm a little scared
oh
I see the universe for its Purity I know
all knowledge there is to know things to
Chinese brain massager my wisdom reach
New Heights
enhanced memory it feels as bit as weird
as it looks
okay okay okay
all right turn it up Jesus okay the goal
is where I have ah Jesus I have a one
more and then I will turn on all of it
at once and I will feel ultimate
pleasure
it's the foot one any converter thank
you Chinese no it's the neck massage
here
come on I forgot I bought these what
even even
[Music]
bro
okay here's some knee pads I'm gonna put
these on my arms because I want every
part of my body that you can see
pleasure just wanted it
cool thanks oh especially for me
especially for me have fun and celebrate
in your favorite day because it's my
special day it's my special day it's my
special day thanks for me I'm a massager
in my brain so special day it needs to
be charged damn it intelligent I'm a
massager I already bought an eye massage
I get two eye massagers why why I get I
got two now the other one looks better
but this looks cooler though I think
I'll go try the cooler one foot massager
finally okay the last one and then we're
gonna get it
gosh
oh these are so good
love it I give that one six okay I feel
like this is like an experiment
because you know brain massage good chin
massage activated the brain massage is
so strong I can't feel it but I will get
a beat let's kind of sting a little bit
I don't know if it's supposed to do that
how how I don't like it
I'm not feeling pleasure I feel pain
stop it I'm initiating back massage
maximum intensity
okay
initiating
neck massage
whoa
oh the balls are moving it's very
uncomfortable I don't like it at all
maybe I'll start to like it
starting foot massage
last step I massage
okay Bros I'm going to the other side
I'll see you in Ultimate Fighter land
oh
I forgot my chin massager
oh this is the YouTube retirement life
baby
oh like And subscribe and you will
become satisfied as well
thanks for watching Pro face
greatest internet browser just got even
greater Opera GX baby while other
browsers will feed you a bunch of
clickbait articles that you don't care
about Opera knows what you like games
and that's what they give you I actually
found a lot of great games through this
stuff I play with friends that I never
would have found otherwise you can
customize exactly how the way you want
you can keep eye on all the new releases
on any single platform but another great
feature that they have is access to a
thousand free games on gxc.gg they
recently had a hashtag Notice Me game
jam with over 300 contesters with the
theme of then the night changed
everything and it brought in some
incredible games this is the winner Moon
leap
I like it
it's cool
next up is all you can take
after that Raven estate
fourth place is skeleton punchers
play soulmaster versus little Beezy
so yeah you can check out all the games
from the gaming I'm in the link in the
description for free with a thousand
other games in this library that are for
free and the best five games chosen by
public vote will receive money tire
prices from a poll of 33 000. thank you
heartbreaks for supporting in the
developers so yeah download Opera GX
today and thanks for watching the video
bye